what is up guys Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 shared a bunch of Gameplay at
Summer Games Fest and we're all super
excited for Modern Warfare 2. Aaron here
in particular actually got to see Modern
Warfare 2 at a press event and we got
our Impressions up already in another
chat if you want to check it out today
though we're gonna turn the lens onto
2019's Modern Warfare and we're going to
talk about just what made that game so
damn good make sure to hit that like
button sub to the channel and let's get
right into it
I think a lot of people really liked how
risky the campaign was in you know
Modern Warfare 2019 what was your what
was your take on that campaign so you
know that campaign to me seemed like it
was the DNA of the original Modern
Warfare Trilogy you know I mean again
this is no shade to Call of Duty ghosts
infinite Warfare Advanced Warfare I
enjoyed those games I enjoyed those
campaigns for what they were but there
was something about the first time when
I played Modern Warfare 2 for example
and those set pieces the action the
chaos and all of that stuff back when I
was younger in high school that just
blew my mind away and getting my hands
on 2019's Modern Warfare it felt like I
was back into that situation again the
campaign was dangerous it was tense it
was kind of scary in a way because you
didn't know who was ready to just kill
you right around the corner everything
was a threat and so the campaign for
Modern Warfare 2019 was a definite
highlight for me and it was one of my
favorite Parts about the game it was
really really clever honestly like the
the mission that everybody always talks
about is the clean house mission that
happened in London yes and it's hard you
know people will feel differently about
that mission but regardless of how you
feel on a technical perspective call of
I don't know if Call of Duty's ever done
a level that only had 11 enemies in it
think about think about that
think about how intense getting through
that mission was how scared you were and
after fighting waves and waves and waves
of enemies and other Call of Duty games
this Mission pulled off one of the most
memorable ecology missions of all time
with 11 enemies yep and the shoot don't
shoot scenarios that happened to that
mission again some of the most memorable
and a Call of Duty game making you not
want to shoot is actually like the
opposite of what every other Call of
Duty game has ever been and it actually
makes it makes you think like you you
genuinely were like afraid and terrified
in that level the Piccadilly level too
uh you might not realize this uh we had
one of our like best gameplay people Max
run through it on the hardest difficulty
but like you were basically running
through your life through this attack
and scared and trying to save people as
best you could you couldn't you couldn't
save everybody but you might not realize
that there was like a ton of different
ways you could go through that too like
it wasn't it wasn't on Rails you you
could literally experience all these
different things by going to different
parts of it so like I think just it
deserves so much credit from a technical
standpoint just from a storytelling
standpoint
um and that's what was so impressive
about a lot of the missions in that
campaign
oh absolutely I mean the campaign just
always had this like it just had this
like umph to it you know there was this
impactful kind of like lasting feeling
that stayed with you even after the
missions went that that uh mission that
you were talking about there near the
end of it there's a hostage and it's
actually the first time when you kind of
see price you know come up he's got this
like veteran really cool like badass
arobada where he's like all right you're
with me let's go Captain brush Soldier
Curry
with me and you're going up and you see
this this hostage with a bomb strapped
to his chest and if this was any other
Call of Duty game I promise you you
would Defuse The Bomb in the nick of
time you know like just a second left
half a second left you would be able to
to save the day but in this case the
tension was ramping up price is looking
at you and he's yelling he's like are
you able to do this and you're like I
can't I can't get it off and so he just
pulls the cord takes the hostage throws
him over the balcony Dives on you to get
out of the way and that hostage blows up
and I was literally just like
I was I I mean I was gobs fact like
there it's so incredible the the set
pieces in that campaign it is so
incredible how uh just you know
adrenaline how much adrenaline is going
through you and if if Modern Warfare
2019 is any indication that makes me
even more excited for the type of
surprises that we could potentially see
in Modern Warfare 2's campaign as well
it's interesting right after the scene
that you mentioned too uh what happened
was I think the main character basically
said well why can't we just take the
gloves off right and then they do they
do take the gloves off and then a couple
scenes later you're like torturing this
dude's family and you don't want yeah
like he
you want to put the gloves back on
you're like no I'm sorry
I'm sorry price like I don't think that
I really want to do this
like just like he's like you want to see
this or do you want to he's like or do
you want to step out like I think you
have that choice if I'm not it was kind
of you were particip you had the kids
nap to the person it was happening
anyway yeah so like yeah I mean I I
think you know some some people didn't
feel like there was any sort of
conclusion after that because you're the
character kind of just sort of went with
it after that point but I think he was
you as a player that was an impactful
moment too where you were like I don't
want to participate in this anymore like
I get why I get why you don't want to
take the gloves off in this particular
case where it ran into some trouble with
some people was just how I think how
close to home it hit like it was very it
was extremely contemporary it dealt with
things that were happening in the world
at that time in particular
um one of the later missions spoilers if
you haven't played this at all stop now
for a second
um you're you know you're chasing a guy
down a tunnel and it doesn't go well it
goes okay but you're basically chasing a
Dude down a tunnel and assassinating
them and at that exact time in real life
that had actually happened
um you know I granted this game had been
in production for years they could have
known it would be happening and within a
two-week span but that was how grounded
and sort of like
real world things and and again like I
understand some people found that to be
uncomfortable
um because like it's some of the stuff
is horrific in real life but my personal
takeaway from the game was that it was
that this stuff is horrific and like it
there's not a lot of right answers here
and it really is pretty terrible and
like that's where the that's where the
campaign left off in my mind
you know one of the best things about
Call of Duty that was actually very
unexpected with the campaign was the
fact that it tiptoed the line really
well between being this like Herculean
character that could just you know Dodge
bullets and and wreck Mayhem versus that
kind of like grounded you know
horrifying realities of war and I I
really do appreciate that I mean you
know I come from Shooters like Halo
where you have Master Chief you know or
from uh adventure games like uh
Assassin's Creed where you're you know
Ezio auditory and having Captain Price
on your team he's like low-key in my
mind on the same level as some of these
uh iconic characters and yet the world
that they are inhabiting in is a world
that is right outside our window you
know what I mean like it's not it's not
uh Renaissance Italy it is not you know
hundreds of years in the future like
this is something that is very very
close to home in a way and I I don't
know they they tipped that line really
well and can we just like talk about
some of those uh missions that don't
really involve you just running and
gunning but the stuff Health Mission
there was one with pharah when she had
to escape her house she was buried under
Rubble as a kid right it's like a very
traumatic memory that you're reliving
and you see her dad and just like you
know the the animation the graphics all
of that stuff felt way too real
especially for me and so you know hiding
in that house uh you know as a kid with
the knife and all that and trying to
like stealth your way around I mean geez
you get goosebumps you know like
they did go a little bit too far with
the kid stabby stabby
it's just I I just let's just put it
this way I just didn't believe it
um you know like it did cross the line I
think you said it right like I think it
rode the line pretty well it did cross
the line at times yeah until like where
I was just like no this this is not this
there's no way that this happens it's
like a 70 pound kid just like
just she said you're going Chucky on
that guy
so okay let's talk about we have to do
like a mental transition here because I
think Call of Duty campaigns in the past
have sometimes been very serious you
know a lot of people talk about no
Russian and some other some other ones
that really stuck with people but let's
be honest like um multiplayer is where
Call of Duty's at campaign you play for
four six eight hours at most then as a
Call of Duty player you spend 100 200
maybe many more hours over in
multiplayer yeah so let's talk about why
Modern Warfare 2019's multiplayer was so
good so fun just such a such a different
take on Call of Duty the core gameplay
Loop was just so good you had a couple
of casuals like me and my friends
pulling out like SEAL Team Six like
tactics I mean this game was just off
the chart with multiplayer I think what
I also really really really enjoyed was
how I want to say heavy some of the guns
have felt now
what I mean by that is for example I've
been playing a lot of Vanguard and
Vanguard is like this weird half step
between Black Ops which is very fast
arcadey uh fast time to kill and Modern
Warfare and Modern Warfare itself just
was so much more like heavier the way
that you ran the way that you would
angle your side so you could Mount Your
Weapon and all this stuff
this was such a very good core Loop I
think it's really important to talk
about that
um you know to put this in context of
time Modern Warfare 2019 came into the
picture when loot boxes were dying out
and it's hard to undersell how important
it was that 2019 got rid of loot boxes
and decided to go another way 2019 also
just had a really good thing going with
you had challenges that led to skins so
you were always you were always working
to get a skin and it was so motivating
like I went across multiple modes I beat
the entire Co-Op campaign and that
that's a whole other conversation but
like I I did it all for skins and now
when I fire up Call of Duty it's
particularly war zone and Vanguard I
feel like there's very few opportunities
to earn skins that I like and it's all
in the store but that wasn't the case
yeah yeah it's so disappointing that
wasn't the case with 2019 2019 it was
like you working really hard for these
challenges to get these skins that
encourage you to do all kinds of
different play Styles which is really
fun
um but the other thing is that they kept
it classy right they knew that it was a
mill Sim game and like the ridiculous
clown skins you see in the game now and
I mean I don't want to throw shade at
Snoop Dogg because he is a friggin he's
a he is a pleasure to play with in
Warzone now and I don't want to take
away from Snoop Dogg but like he didn't
belong in 2019 right and like the the I
think the craziest skin they had was
like this trash skin it was like a
ghillie suit full of trash that was
actually really fun
um I I I'm a hypocrite I did buy one or
two anime skins but
but like in general they kept it classy
for a very long time so you are earning
these very like well thought out cool
looking military inspired skins you also
got to unlock the base operator and all
these different like realistic Special
Forces factions it didn't get silly
until later and I really appreciated
that and that's something that um I'm
excited that actually they've you know
they've announced that war zone 2 will
be a clean slate clean start and Modern
Warfare 2 should do the same thing just
keep it classy for like a year I get it
you know you're gonna get to clowns
eventually but like give give us a good
year of clownless
yeah or like Santa Claus you know skins
in December or something I mean it just
it goes to show Modern Warfare knew its
audience right like these guys they want
their combat to feel decisive they want
the combat to feel tactical and most
importantly you want it to feel
deliberate you know
that's just it's just a a recipe for
Success it was also a game that had a
good mix of things for different people
um granted these were for Milson people
they weren't for it wasn't as much and I
don't want to repeat myself to death
because we have said this so many times
but it was a game that wasn't so much
made for the Cold War Vanguard fans it
was made for the lapse Battlefield
players the people like the mill Sims
way to your combat
um and because of that it was large open
porous Maps which I personally loved
um but I think people like those three
lane Maps who are the core quality crowd
but the sandbox was just magnificent
like the first preview event that we
went to seeing a sniper on a rooftop and
nailing him with a javelin shot from
above or like you know hacking
claymore's out from under Campers or
learning that you could use a smoke
grenade and thermal sites putting the um
the grenade Interceptor on top of
vehicles
it's that's that's where it's at it's
this just give me tools and just let me
do what I want and that's exactly what
what they did in 2019. okay so the next
thing to talk about and David I think
you were mentioning a lot about how
creative a live service you thought war
zone was but yeah let's talk about war
zone so what went right there in 2019
the thing about Warzone that was great
is they seemed to learn from their
experience with blackout I really really
liked the original Warzone map it seemed
familiar it was basically different
sections of maps that you might have
already played before so you weren't
completely caught off guard or
completely lost the weapons the gameplay
nothing felt entirely off other than
maybe you know giving players more armor
right because it is a battle royale but
I think one of the most jarring things
when it comes to playing different Call
of Duty games is the different you know
weight in the different gameplay Loops
between uh different games but Modern
Warfare and Warzone the difference was
very negligible and so it kind of felt
like riding a bike right you've been
here before you've done it before it
didn't feel completely unnatural which
is smart because not everyone is into
battle royale's right it's it's not for
everyone it's a little bit more high
stakes if you're not really getting a
lot of kills it can be not as fun and so
having someone who could play a lot of
multiplayer in Modern Warfare Turn To
War zombie like let me give this a try
and then feel right at home speaks
volumes it's hard to understate how
groundbreaking it was that the war zone
map was just made of the other Maps yeah
so there was a gap between the launch of
2019 and War Zone uh there will be again
with Modern Warfare 2 it'll be like a
month or two but in that time you were
learning every single location on the
war zone map without knowing it somebody
found out that if you actually flew out
of Superstore I think it was you could
see the proto-war zone map I did it and
it was true but the first time that you
landed on that map you knew where you
were because you'd seen that map in
ground war or core multiplayer yeah and
it wasn't until the map started getting
changed from other games being added
later that it became something you had
to learn
but it was freaking brilliant man like
you just you already knew the map and
they and you didn't even know you were
being trained on that map ahead of time
with warzone
I mean with battle royale's in general
you have live service and live service
tropes and one of the biggest things
that live service uh games have been
kind of implementing has been expanding
upon World lore and World building
character development things like that
and Modern Warfare did the same thing
the story of your campaign characters
did not end with the campaign even
though you thought it might have right I
mean you know there was a time where I
thought it was Alex I believe who seemed
like you know again spoiler alert for
those who haven't played the campaign
but it seemed like he was you know a
very self-righteous sacrifice uh ready
to be made you know at the end of The
Campaign and yet one of the biggest
teases in like season one or season two
of War Zone was Alex returning as an
operator right or actually you know so
season one was Ghost I think I think it
was ghost who shows up you know which
was really really cool and so I I mean
it's it's taking what players love about
this world and just expanding upon it
giving people more and in a way and
through a free to play Avenue which is
that's great I mean that's that give me
more of that that's what I want
with all of the great bones and DNA that
modeling for 2019 offers what would you
like to see Modern Warfare 2 kind of
take from that or maybe even try
differently
Modern Warfare 2 from what I've seen so
far so I did go to a preview event and I
can talk about anything that they told
us I also played like an hour or two and
I'm not allowed to talk about how it
feels but a lot of the things were the
same things they talked about
um so like I will say that Modern
Warfare 2 so far is looking really good
for Modern Warfare 2019 fans and almost
every area except one the one area is I
did feel like the core maps were still
trying to like cater I only saw a couple
of them so like take this with a grain
of salt I did feel like they said that
they were smaller and they were trying
to be more competitive so I think they
were trying to cater a little bit more
towards the the Cold War traditional
Call of Duty audience but the ground war
maps are all much bigger and they're
more purpose-built and War zones getting
a clean slate and you know like we see
the weaponsmith and everything happen in
there
so like I'm fairly sold on what I've
seen so far
um the tool set is there some of the
tools
I'm gonna have to mess with them I
laughed a lot about in the preview about
a blow up Demi
um
the I don't know how useful it's gonna
be it's just gonna be really funny and
hilarious to use half the time there's a
drill charge that you can throw through
wall ceilings and Floors which is super
fun there's a camera system you can
throw out on the map a lot of these seem
very like Rainbow Six Siege
inspired
um so I don't know if those tools are
like great new additions or not we're
just gonna have to see but also they're
expanding things like uh damage to
Vehicles which is super cool
um bumpers can get blown off doors can
get blown out tires can get popped and
that's an exp that's it everywhere so
that's an expansion from Warzone so yeah
like I think everything for the for the
milsim crowd who's like the bigger maps
and the vehicles it is all looking
pretty good and giving me what I want
I'm afraid that they're going to
continue the I have no evidence for this
but I'm afraid they're gonna continue
The Not So Great Loop that we were
talking about earlier which is like
don't I don't want the Skins to be
locked in the store I want skins to be
things that I earn
I you might feel differently I do not
care about anything else like I don't
care about emblems I don't care about I
don't care about anything else that that
you earn in this game the only thing I
care about is skins so for me as a
player like I'm not an achievement
hunter I just like visual things
um you know I like weapon blueprints
that's all I want are weapon Blueprints
and skins and Warzone has taken the game
in a different direction I hope they get
away from that because it shouldn't be
locked in the store yeah that's probably
the one the one red flag in my mind
um but yeah it I think everything else
is looking pretty on track and pretty
fantastic how about you David what what
are you looking for man I mean if if you
know the beginning of the of the chat
didn't already make it clear I'm a
campaign boy through and through and I'm
most most most excited to see soap
return I I mean like I said you know
with the original Modern Warfare Trilogy
I started with modern warfare 2. so I
actually Captain Price came later into
the the legendary Mythos in my mind you
know it was always a soap and brooch
that little Duo tandem that I would play
as and seeing soap return I'm I'm
excited man I I think it's going to be
awesome I can't wait to see the the task
141 return and and you know in like the
The Glory Days like at their Peak right
at the at their Peak Performance and you
know I just can't wait to see what kind
of set pieces in particular uh they have
in store for us in the campaign Modern
Warfare set pieces are always absolutely
balls to the wall crazy you know what I
mean you're either breaking through uh
you know rooftops of as you're slipping
off of mountain tops or things like that
you're blowing up poor innocent hostages
because you can't you know diffuse them
in time it's it's it's a good time in
the campaign and I'm I you know actually
the summer games Fest uh gameplay that
they showed I liked what I saw even
though it looked a lot like modern
warfare one's original kind of like uh
boarding the ship Mission but it looked
great man and and I'm excited to see
more
they're they're going a lot for that in
the campaign it sounds like the campaign
is made up of the greatest hits of other
Call of Duty levels yeah with their own
with their own twist on it so that could
work out really cool so that is US
waxing nostalgic about Modern Warfare
2019 and all the things that we thought
it did right but this is subjective you
might have your own opinions about this
or you might have been a cold war fan
who just you know didn't like that large
open style at all so let us know in the
comments below we read the comments and
we include them in a lot of our videos
while you're at it head on over to
Gamespot we have a written preview of
the the two hours that we went down to
infinity and talked about Modern Warfare
2. can't show you gameplay just yet but
I promise we will as soon as we can and
head over and check out our video over
on YouTube okay thank you so much for
watching everyone
[Music]
thank you